someone told me that during quarantine
this you know this last year you've been
getting into
witchcraft a little bit experimenting is
that true or false
yeah it's true but listen i want to say
that
um i'm not an expert
i don't pretend to know you know all the
secrets of the dark arts
i'm an apprentice to a fourth generation
witch
called dandelion who lives across the
street from me
i'm blessed that she has taken me under
her
advisement and learned a lot
seen a lot and i'm just dabbling
okay you're dabbling in the dark arts
and that's fine that's something a lot
of people do
in show business um my question is
what are your powers have you learned to
do anything can you
can you read into the future can you
what can you do what have you learned
with your
witchcraft apprenticeship one thing is
i've been getting very good at readings
i have my cards right here
okay um you know mainly what i do is i
just harness
the energy of the moon the stars the
galactic
cosmic void right into my
and and i use it for the power of good
uh-huh okay and
and sometimes i change someone's life
like yours conan
really right now i'm harnessing the
energy of the mediterranean sea which is
very nearby my room
i feel the waves i hear you my
darling and i will
harness this energy right into the cards
now conan yeah i don't control
the outcome of these readings so if i
pull a card that you don't like
that's on you baby
you heard it here first okay all right
so what do i do do i pick one or is it
just gonna appear
now i'm gonna just slowly cascade these
cards down
and when you get the feeling deep down
inside of you
you say hold it mama i think those are
just bar coasters but anyway
uh hold on
now mama
oh conan this is a good
card baby this is the four of disks
four of disks what's happening in that
it looks like someone's trying to flee a
small
apartment that's on fire
you're right this does not look
promising no that does not look like i
wanted to get a card where like
a naked guy is with a naked lady and
it's all about
sex and my sexuality and
this woman wants out she wants out of
your life
conan the woman that's closest to you
is not happy that's my wife fleeing our
marriage as if the house is on fire is
that what you're saying your marriage is
the fire
conan and you have not been tending to
it
no i have not been tending those fires
and that's my wife or is that
jesus i don't pretend to know
your religion these cards are up for
interpretation but i will say that
that's a very
small hole she's trying to crawl out of
look like i said i'm an apprentice
okay but i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna for real i'm gonna email you
later and tell you what this really
means
okay do tell me what that means because
it looks doesn't look good it looks like
yeah it looks like my wife is unhappy
with the marriage and is trying to get
out
of our tiny hut that we live in i don't
want to
i don't want to be presumptuous but that
could be you
i mean doesn't that kind of look like
you you know if my hair was a little
longer that could be me
and it doesn't look like it's a door it
i don't know what that is
it looks like a space to hide something
in
i'm very intrigued i love it like i said
i don't control the outcome nope only
your destiny baby
yep you've told me absolutely nothing
and i enjoyed it
um you know we got it you will
so you've had no gummies in a while is
that what you're saying
this is you with no gummies
i'm high on turkey honey
apple gobble okay yes gobble gobble
the turkish people love it when we
pretend it's the actual bird
you